as if
2020 wasn't strange enough already
the san francisco golden gate bridge
remains shrouded in smoke
in a pale comparison to what the morning
commute looked like this week
smoke and ash from wildfires mixed with
the cool pacific ocean air
to produce an otherworldly effect
11 15.
crazy 11 15 in the morning and it's
like the middle of the night almost
historic
fires are ripping through three western
states
in california almost 5 000 square
kilometers have burned
firefighters don't expect to bring the
blazes under control until the middle of
october
some villages have already been
incinerated
the governor toured one scorched forest
making a point about climate change as
he surveyed the damage
this is a climate damn emergency this is
real
and it's happening this is the perfect
storm it is happening
unprecedented ways year in year out the
debate is over
around climate change just come to the
state
of california a driver in oregon filmed
the dramatic scenes as an
inferno engulfed the forests
while this footage reveals the total
obliteration the fires left
in their wake the governor told
residents to brace for a huge loss of
life and property and said that many
residents were missing
in washington state too fires have
wrecked havoc
and heartbreak everything gone clothes
beds everything though weather
conditions are gradually improving
meteorologists are warning that it is
not yet even
peak wildfire season